if you ask 10 people what their favorite
game of 2019 is you'll likely get 10
different answers we saw everything from
conspiracy laced adventure romps to
mind-bending indie gems to sublime
remakes of legendary titles it wasn't
just a year when there was something for
everyone but more impressively something
new for everyone so it's continually
baffled me that so many of you nerds and
your moms seem to have labeled the year
a misstep news and leaks about the Xbox
series X and PS 5 have dominated much of
the years news yes but in the spaces
between studios have released a handful
of legitimately brilliant video games in
some ways these twelve months felt
almost like an extension of the 2018
year of our Lord Danny DeVito by that I
mean that 2019 was defined just as much
by its indie titles as by its triple-a
tentpoles
but even more so than 2018 and any other
year really in recent memory 2019 felt
like the year when Studios weren't
afraid to get weird and in this case no
other game can embody Exhibit A better
than death stranding say what you will
about Kojima Productions first outing as
a collective group call it vapid call it
brilliant call it groundbreaking or
downright terrible there's an argument
for each of these and for the better
part of 2019
those conversations aka fistfights
permeated the Internet even before the
game released but one thing nobody seems
able or willing to refute death
stranding is bold
it's an arthouse indie game with a
triple-a budget from the guy who has
long been synonymous with video game
auteur and guess what you'll spend most
of it 60 to 70 hours walking around
delivering packages and lobbing urine
grenades at ethereal shadow beings I
severely dislike death stranding myself
I've made that clear on numerous
occasions but I can't deny it rocked the
boat and whether I like it or not it
will be the game many of us associate
with 2019 here's hoping Sony continues
to fund such eccentric projects just
make
a little better next in the arena of
weird 2019 will forever go down in
history as the year we finally received
an answer to that age-old question what
kind of game do you make after you've
dabbled in time travel police dramas
television experiments and the Stephen
King school of horror you make control
dummies Remini entertainment has been
pumping so much bizarre out of Finland
for years now I wouldn't be surprised
you could see the studio from space
control combines conspiracy theories
brutalist architecture and the x-files
reruns to such effect that obsessive
players are still active daily on reddit
they're unfolding the mysteries remedy
hid for them and in some cases imagining
some that probably aren't actually there
elsewhere in the what drugs where these
developers taking when they made this
game and where can I get some and do
they accept layaway department we have
baba is you puzzle games need a strong
identity to separate themselves from the
pack baba is you does this not with
clever platforming or drastic shifts in
perspective but by toying with language
itself by arranging troglodytic
sentences yes I had to Google that to
stop interrupting me you actually change
the rules to get where you need to go
it's a clever subversive take on a genre
built around rigid rule sets for many
players Baba as you seemingly came out
of nowhere
and it was not the only game to do so
some of the year's best games released
too little initial fanfare only to punch
everyone in their enjoyment bones as
reviews rolled in count a plague tale
innocence among that crowd its focus
Home Interactive first original title
since 2008 and its sights of all games
The Last of Us as its chief inspiration
whether because of the studio's decade
of relative silence or the caliber of
the game it was trying to live up to it
came as a surprise to learn that
innocence is good it's very good it's a
gorgeous moving adventure through a
decaying medieval France it tells a
poignant story about siblings death and
family bonds and it's well worth
checking out if you've ignored it thus
far the same goes for avoid Basterds one
of my personal 2019 favorites I made an
entire video about how well it combines
the shooter strategy and rogue
like genres and how it stands on the
shoulders of giants to reach something
altogether fresh its vibrant and chaotic
and belies an intelligent set of
survival systems and planning strategies
to modify that age-old idiom fans of the
genres will find plenty to love here and
speaking of genres see RPGs got a major
shot in the arm this year in the form of
disco Elysium the isometric role-playing
game puts you in the wing tip shoes of a
bloated detective whose life is to put
it lightly falling the [ __ ] apart but
like any good trainwreck things tend to
get more interesting the farther from
the rails you get disco Elysium is a
beautifully written secretly heartfelt
game about everything from capitalism to
the intricacies of human cognition
what's more it made us all feel better
about the one time we fell into the
toilet hungover and splashed around for
like nine seconds before just giving up
and lying there because it wasn't
actually all that bad how many games can
wring empathy from a situation like that
SEC ero can't but there's a lot Sakura
can do it can combine expert level
design with vibrant Japanese historical
fiction it can create some of the most
rewarding combat encounters of the souls
borne genre which from software itself
created of course resulting in a game
that breaks you down before building you
back up its game spots collective number
one game of the year and we made a whole
video about how good it is quickly
before I end the video I have some loose
ends to tie up a Resident Evil 2 remake
is a masterclass in how it balances
omage with momentum I could have spoken
more about it but chances are you
already know how good it is to respond
entertainment continues to be one of the
best devs in the biz releasing the
extraordinarily good apex legends and
branching out of first-person shooters
with the extremely solid Star Wars Jedi
falling order D Call of Duty is better
than it's been since the first black ops
in fight me now it's time to end this
video and to be honest I'm having
trouble doing so it was a long year full
of wonderful games that I got to cover
and even now I feel like I'm cheating
hundreds of talented developers who made
them all a reality to narrow my list
down to 10
let alone one doesn't just feel
reductive but feels like an active
obstacle as I sit here and finish this
script but like I said GameSpot already
picked a number one game and a great
game ended up winning but this is my
video and in this world I'm the one in
charge so I'm going to wrap up
everything by recommending
wholeheartedly if I have to pick one
game that you should play from 2019 I'm
gonna go with my favorite its outer
wilds outer wilds begins on a charming
planet populated by friendly aliens and
covered in evergreen trees it then
gradually expands into a story about an
entire [ __ ] solar system it's a
marvel of world-building and level
design and how the two can intersect in
revelatory ways
it houses clever puzzles and intelligent
detective mechanics it harkens back to
classics such as Majora's Mask and mist
and it does them just as ten times over
it stresses the importance of time death
Oh rejuvenation knowledge curiosity and
wisdom and by the time the credits roll
you'll be thinking about the universe
and your place in it and how you got to
where you are right now and you'll fall
in love with the video games all over
again and you'll have the Wizards at
mobius digital to thank for it I'd
apologize for the hyperbole but honestly
I'm not being hyperbolic outer wilds is
that good I don't have much to say as we
wade into 2020 but as this video and
2019 wrap-up I can say one thing with
certainty
you should play outer wilds
[Music]